hello everyone welcome to the langfocus
channel and my name is paul today's
topic is
the irish language or
as it's called in irish in english we
have the word gaelic which may refer to
irish
but irish people generally don't call it
gaelic in english
and they don't call it irish gaelic many
people will insist
it's irish just irish irish is a member
of the gaelic or goydelik language group
one of the two groups of insular celtic
languages the celtic languages that
developed in ireland and britain
and are still in existence today for
more background information on the
celtic languages in general
check out my video on that topic right
here
irish is spoken in you guessed it
ireland
that includes both the republic of
ireland and northern ireland
there are three main dialects of irish
munster
konacht and ulster it's difficult to get
statistics about the number of native
speakers of irish but according to the
republic of ireland census of 2016
there are around 74 000 daily speakers
of irish
outside of the education system which is
less than two percent of the population
and there are a little over four
thousand native speakers in northern
ireland
but there are close to two million
second language speakers with at least
some knowledge of irish and it's a
required subject in schools in the
republic of ireland which many students
love to complain about
history it's not certain exactly when
celtic language speakers came to ireland
but it was probably more than 2
500 years ago there are no records of
the language from that time period
the oldest form of goydelk that we know
was archaic irish or primitive irish
we have samples from the om inscriptions
dating to the early 4th century ce
they are inscribed in stone in the om
alphabet
and mainly consist of fragments
containing personal names
during this period of the alm
inscriptions in other words the
primitive irish period
irish speakers migrated from ireland to
scotland
and to the isle of man where the irish
language would eventually evolve into
two different languages scottish gaelic
or garlic as they call it
and manx by the 7th century archaic
irish had evolved into old irish
of which there are longer written texts
in existence old irish was written until
the 10th century
by which time it had already developed
into an early stage of middle irish
writings during the middle irish period
show emerging dialectal variation in the
different areas where it was spoken
the late old irish period and the early
middle irish period were characterized
by viking raids and norse settlement in
ireland
which had some impact on the vocabulary
of irish but the grammar wasn't really
affected
some of the norse loanwords that entered
irish are in
meaning penny and marugu meaning market
and some vocabulary relating to ships
and navigation
in the late 12th century the norman
invasion of ireland took place
when anglo-normans conquered and settled
the land
the language of the new ruling class was
norman french which was used alongside
irish and english the language of many
of the commoners who moved from england
to ireland during that time
in large part they were eventually
assimilated and became
more irish than the irish themselves and
irish became the most widely spoken
language again
but norman french left its mark on irish
in some dialects more than others
loanwords from norman french include
carson
meaning
meaning church and many more that was
all happening during the period of
classical irish
from the 13th to 18th centuries
classical irish was a literary language
learned by poets and scholars
and it remained relatively unchanged
during this time period
but the spoken language known as early
modern irish kept
gradually evolving towards modern irish
irish remains the most widely spoken
language until around the year 1800 but
english control meant that the english
language was the prestige language
and the more prosperous irish began
adopting the english language in greater
numbers
then the great famine of 1846 to 1848
disproportionately impacted the poor who
were mainly irish speakers
around 1 million people died and around
1 million emigrated during the famine
the irish language became seriously
endangered and limited to certain areas
most of them isolated rural areas
another factor in the decline of irish
was the introduction of national schools
state-funded primary schools which
prohibited the use of irish and enforced
an english-only policy
until 1871. in the late 19th century a
revival was underway with an irish
language newspaper
literature and successful efforts to
make the irish language part of the
school curriculum
part of this process was the development
of a standard language to unite the
various dialects
which was completed in 1958 now
irish is a living language with an
existing community of native speakers
it's the first official language of the
republic of ireland
and it's widely studied as a heritage
language in schools
but it's still considered endangered as
a spoken native language
something that many irish people hope to
change so
what is irish like phonology broad and
slender consonants
one important feature of irish is that
most written consonants have
two different pronunciations broad and
slender
broad consonants have a velarized
pronunciation meaning that the back of
your tongue
raises towards the soft palate or velum
when you produce the consonant sound
slender consonants have a palatalized
pronunciation
meaning that the middle of the tongue is
raised towards the hard palate
in modern irish orthography the adjacent
vowels
indicate whether the consonant is broad
or slender
the broad vowels are a o and u
and the narrow vowels are i and e
for example meaning what and
in the first word this a is a broad
vowel so the c
is pronounced as a broad consonant the
hard k sound
a voiceless velar stop the d is also
broad
this symbol here indicates valorization
the k here doesn't need that symbol
because it already represents a velar
consonant
in the second word this slender e vowel
is added to indicate that the c
is pronounced as a slender consonant in
other words it's palatalized
another example meaning pac
and meaning sin in the first word we see
the broad vowel
a twice so the p and the c both
represent
broad consonants in the second word
again the e is a slender vowel
so the p is palatalized in other words
slender
note that when you see a slender and
broad consonant side by side like this
the one closest to the consonant
indicates slenderness or broadness but
often
isn't pronounced as a vowel itself
another example
meaning yellow and e meaning be
this vowel and consonant are broad and
this vowel and consonant are slender
again this u is not pronounced as a
vowel but just
indicates that the preceding consonant
is broad the basic rule is
which means slender with slender broad
with broad
this means that in the middle of a word
slender vowels must appear on both sides
of a slender consonant
and broad vowels must appear on both
sides of a broad consonant
for example here the r or double r
must have a broad vowel both before and
after even though the one
after it is not pronounced as a vowel
itself
also when consonants appear together in
a cluster they must all share the same
broad or slender quality
for example meaning question both the s
and t are slender due to the preceding
eye vowel
initial consonant mutations another
feature of irish phonology
is initial consonant mutations a change
in a consonant at the beginning of a
word in certain grammatical contexts
there are two types of initial consonant
mutation
lenitin or chevu and eclipses
or first lunition in most cases but not
all
this type of mutation causes a stop to
become a fricative
for example bam meaning woman becomes
velm after the definite article in the
accusative case
a vam linition is shown in writing by
placing the letter
h after the original consonant another
example
is after singular possessive adjectives
take this word
meaning mother my mother would be moahes
notice that the initial consonant is
pronounced more like
rather than a bilabial nasal m sound
this type of mutation also occurs after
certain prepositions
and in other contexts next eclipses
this type of mutation usually involves a
voiceless stop becoming voiced
or a voiced stop becoming a nasal like
clinician
eclipses happens in certain grammatical
environments such as after plural
possessive adjectives
so the word for children is porshti but
to say our children
it's e this is shown in writing by
adding the letter
representing the new sound in front of
the original one
and it's used after some combinations of
dative prepositions plus the singular
definite article
for example bird meaning table but
on the table is is a murde and also
after the preposition
e without the definite article for
example
meaning house but in a house is
it's also used with certain numbers
board
boat shaft mode seven boats
by the way it's worth noting here that
in standard irish for non-human nouns
the singular form is used when counting
though in dialects the plural forms are
used as well
so why do these mutations appear in
these different environments that seem
to have little to do with each other
well it's because in an earlier stage of
irish they appeared in clear phonetic
environments
lenition occurred between vowels both
within words and across word boundaries
and eclipses took place after a nasal
sound their purpose was to allow
speech to flow without pauses some of
these vowel sounds and nasal sounds were
part of grammatical endings that have
since
disappeared so now the mutations
themselves indicate or give hints about
that grammatical information
prepositions another interesting element
of irish is its use of prepositions like
egg age
they can be used on their own with
definite articles or with personal
pronominal endings
when used alone or with a definite
article they work much the same way as
they do in english
but you might recall that in the
previous section on initial consonant
mutation
we saw that many prepositions when used
with the singular definite article cause
eclipses like in the phrase meaning on
the table
or is a mod meaning on the boat
the most interesting part is that you
can add a suffix to the preposition
which acts like a personal pronoun
so in the sentence meaning
he gave the money to me means to me
means to and the nasal means me
to us would be and so on
along with the suffix which is added the
preposition itself
also changes a little in many cases as
you can see in the parts that are
highlighted in blue
these are the inflected forms of the
prepositions
this preposition egg meaning at can be
used to show possession
since there's no separate word meaning
to have in irish
for example this sentence means i have a
brother
word for word it's is brother at me
numbers the number system in irish is
fairly complex
first of all there are three types of
cardinal numbers numbers used to count
disjunctive numbers these are numbers
that are used in calculations phone
numbers telling the time
and other contexts when they're not
counting a noun that follows
a particle a normally comes before them
with an h
prefix before initial vowels non-human
conjunctive numbers
these are numbers used to count
non-human nouns most of these are the
same as the disjunctive numbers without
the preceding
a or a h but note that the numbers 1
2 and 4 are different note that numbers
2 to 6
cause the noun to undergo lenition in
the initial consonant
and for the number one it's optional if
this word n
is also here and number seven to ten
caused the noun to undergo eclipses
human conjunctive numbers as you can
probably guess these are numbers used to
count human nouns
these ones are significantly different
in form from the others
notably in these suffixes on many of the
numbers
let's take the number eight as an
example if you're simply counting on
your fingers it's
if you're counting horses it's couple
if you're counting children it's
octoposty
if you're counting books it's lower
if you are counting sisters it's
that sentence means i have eight sisters
counting to two a doll two dogs
two children that's 40.
and there are also ordinal numbers
numbers we use to indicate order
like first second etc most of these are
related to the cardinal numbers
but have different suffixes or other
differences in form
but this one is completely different
verbs there are two categories of
regular verbs in irish
first conjugation and second conjugation
as well as irregular verbs
irish conjugations involve a combination
of suffixes and personal pronouns
in the present tense conjugations we see
here the first person singular and first
person plural have synthetic endings
endings that tell us person and number
so a subject pronoun isn't necessary
the other forms have an analytic ending
one that tells us nothing about person
and number so the verb needs to be
followed by a pronoun
first conjugation verbs and second
conjugation verbs
simply take somewhat different endings
in the first conjugation the endings are
m for the first person singular emits
for the first person plural
and um for the others that's when the
verb base contains a broad vowel before
the final consonant
if a slender vowel appears there then
the endings are
m ahmad um in the second conjugation the
endings are
imits in with a broad stem and
image in with a slender stem
that's just in the present tense there
are a variety of different tenses
including the imperfect
in other words the habitual past the
preterit in other words the simple past
the future and the conditional which all
use a combination of synthetic endings
and analytic endings with pronouns
some sentences now that we've examined a
few key features of irish let's look at
a few sentences and see what we find
before we briefly saw this sentence
meaning he gave me the money
okay let's take a closer look
word for word it's prefix
money to me first off we can see that
the most basic word order of irish is
vso
verb subject object this word
is the past indicative analytic form of
the verb
always like we saw with the present
tense verb forms before
analytic means that this verb form
doesn't tell us anything about person or
number so a pronoun is needed
and this is the pronoun right here means
he
next is the singular definite article
this word is the word for money and like
we saw before
this word is an inflected preposition
a combination of meaning to and the
prefix
meaning me now what's this t doing here
this is similar to the initial consonant
mutations that we saw before
it's inserted between the article um and
nouns beginning with a vowel
it's also inserted before nouns
beginning in s in some contexts
for example swords meaning street
and meaning the street the specifics of
when this happens are somewhat
complicated as they are with the
mutations that we saw before
another sentence this one means i have
to get up early
word for word it's is on me rise
adverb particle early the first word
is the present indicative analytic
habitual form of the verb be
this present tense form applies to
general actions and states that are
habitual
not to those that are only true for the
current moment so this sentence means i
have to get up early
on a regular basis not just once to say
i have to get up early as in
only tomorrow it would be galore
this is also a present tense form of the
verb be
but is not habitual next we see another
inflected preposition
which means on me so saying it is on me
expresses obligation in irish next we
have a verb meaning
to rise this form is a verbal noun which
is often used where we would use the two
infinitive in english and where the
present participle the ing form is used
in english
next we see the word go which has a
number of different usages
but in this case it functions to turn
the next word into an adverb
loa is an adjective meaning fast or
early
but together with it functions as an
adverb
let's go back to the first word for a
minute like i said before
this is a form of the verb be which
means to be
this is a special verb with many
different forms that other verbs don't
have
including the present habitual that we
saw before and a special negative form
that negates the regular present tense
so we have to autumn meaning i need to
wake up early
and that becomes meaning i don't have to
wake up early
the highlighted words are all forms of
the verb be
but this is not the only verb meaning to
be in irish
there's another verb is is is used when
you want to say what someone or
something
is one noun or pronoun is equivalent to
another noun or pronoun
the verb be is used when you want to
describe someone or something
so there's often a noun or a pronoun
with an adjective to describe it
so we have it's moon thoughty meaning
she's a teacher
and meaning she is kind
but means she's a kind person
here kind person is a noun phrase so we
use is
also note the difference in the personal
pronouns e
is a form of the personal pronoun that
is used specifically with is
she is the regular subject form
wow there's a lot to take in when
dealing with the irish language
it sure is interesting but it's also a
little overwhelming and
intimidating every aspect of the
language seems to be filled with details
and rules that need to be learned and
practiced
but in spite of that or maybe because of
that a lot of people who choose to study
irish for their own reasons really go
deep down the rabbit hole and get into
it and study it passionately
in this video we can only barely scratch
the surface but if you decide to study
the irish language
a fascinating journey awaits you the
question of the day
for learners of irish what's been your
experience in learning the language what
have you found challenging what have you
found interesting
and for native speakers of irish what
elements of the language do you think
that learners need to focus on the most
a number of native speakers have told me
how disturbed they are by the lack of
authentic pronunciation among learners
of irish
they were referring specifically to
people who learn irish at school
they told me that most teachers of irish
don't know authentic
irish phonology so they teach irish with
english phonemes
missing the distinction between broad
and slender consonants for example
do you agree with that assessment be
sure to follow langfocus on facebook
twitter and
instagram and as always many many thanks
to my patreon supporters especially
my top tier patreon supporters these
lovely people right here on the screen
many many thanks to them and to everyone
thank you for watching and have a nice
day
[Music]
so
you